hey gang welcome to the ru garbage
comedy podcast
make sure you subscribe so you get the
videos as they come out
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there
and welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast
this is are you garbage to show we sit
down with your favorite comedians
we found the group classy or if they're
absolute trash i'm your host holy coming
at you
on a little bit of a tense day down here
aunt cody's baseball oh boy
i was upstairs getting a sandwich and i
saw her and she got wind of the sellout
on the new
are you garbage home game oh yeah and
she's looking for a little bit of cake
she wants to wet her beak
she wants to wet her beak she mentioned
the name that dirtbags never want to
hear
judge judy oh [ __ ] it's all small claims
i've been here before teddy might have
another tv credit coming up
she's [ __ ] on the prowl um my co-host
coming at you from right next to me he's
wearing his christmas flannel
looks fantastic that's a christmas
present i like how we got we got some
star power in here we both wear collared
shirts like [ __ ] [ __ ]
we're both typically in pajamas i wanted
to look nice
we got hutch coming in you better dress
up i gotta take a shower
it's school picture day give it up for
the boss man kippy kevin james ryan
everybody gang thanks for having me big
man i appreciate it
uh as always please make sure you're on
the lease yeah of course
i have i'm the only one with keys please
make sure you rate me if you subscribe
on itunes oh yeah full video available
on youtube oh yeah subscribe there those
numbers are true to [ __ ] roof
and then patreon.com you can sign up you
get bonus content uh
you can get epis bonus episodes of ayg
episodes of hard feelings we do live
streams
it's a whole [ __ ] scene on there baby
get involved
yes sir and have a nice little quick
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
the pride of the chicago comedy scene
give it up for t-bone mcmuffin
toby mcmullen everybody what's up dude
what's up t-bomb harry is it a little
bud light commercial dude like that dude
[ __ ] yeah i'm doing great man i just
found out that i was a civil war general
in a bad
life that explains the haircut t-bone
this guy's all hopped up on goofball
t-bone is teasing our incredibly special
guest that's here with us today
that has certain views on the afterlife
which one in america
you can have views that you want uh this
is a family episode we got a little
company in the house
if you haven't seen her episode please
go back and check it out
it was one of our early zoo maps one of
the original og's
came in did us a solid was on the pod we
[ __ ] love her you guys love her
she has a brand new podcast out right
now called the voices in her head
and of course she is one half of the
amazing guys we
[ __ ] only on luminary do me a favor
give me a nice big round of applause
for the one the only christina
hutchinson everybody
yeah thank you happy to be here you were
both staring at me in that last room i
thought you were like waiting for me to
mess up you're the host of the show what
uh
yeah there you go relax stay awhile will
ya help a decaf over here or something
this guy's all [ __ ] tense buddy good
to see you yeah thanks for coming
guys i love this place thank you it
reminds me of home
oh yeah i come from garbage too bourbon
philly trash uh-huh
[Music]
[Laughter]
let's stop running your [ __ ] mouth
over there t-bone over there and scratch
your eyeballs out
uh-huh
when did you get that recently or was
that like a year ago almost exactly
last february in philly i was headlining
helium which i'm gonna be doing again
in two months or whatever that's a pro
right there
i love it well every time i'm like oh
every time i had like helium i want to
get a tattoo
uh what are you going to get next like
the philly fanatic or something no
oh my god no do you do the colored ones
like saggalow does
i want to oh does he have colored
tattoos well he has like a whole
car oh he's covered yeah he's real trash
tattoos not just like the outline
well so i want to do that yeah i want to
have more but i i
i i'm dipping my toe into the tattoo is
that your first tattoo
no that's my second i got one on my on
my finger what's that
it says wwbd um it was written by nadine
strauss and who's the first female
president of the american civil
liberties
union and it stands for what would
beyonce too oh my god
and i i got it with uh matching with my
best friend that i don't talk to anymore
some things don't last forever you know
what do you get though yeah you move on
stick to the water it's gonna be like a
class yeah the first female president of
north american civil liberties oh it's
beyonce tattoo yeah
i don't get it yeah how was it then say
it to me one more time so we
the handwriting we wanted the
handwriting if we could to be
someone that we look up to um my friend
and i that we don't talk to anymore
this was her mentor she's a lawyer so um
yeah and she's this amazing woman who's
written a lot of books on free speech
and porn oh so you had her her
handwriting yeah we yeah we went out to
dinner with her and we asked her if she
would hand write our tattoo
wow that's [ __ ] deep yeah she was she
suggested one of the things she knew
ruth bader ginsburg so at the at the
dinner she was like oh maybe
we maybe ruth would do it we're like oh
wait that's yeah actually we want that
but then we're like
i feel bad we kind of took you to this
dinner to ask if you could write it so
she's
she's a very accomplished lady and so
i'm glad it's her handwriting who paid
for dinner
oh i think she no i think we split it
right we're working women
yeah we got jobs and bank accounts how
do you feel about if you go out all
right
this is a kind of a segue into it how if
you go out to dinner with a group of
people
say there's five people yeah how do you
like doing it well you'd put your card
down and take and say hey venmo me
do you chop it up or do you go hey i had
the chicken fingers charged me the night
right
now let's say five successful people
fight you out some of your peers we
split
we split it well just chop it down the
middle yeah and i am and i will drink
based on how much everybody else drinks
oh i don't do that really yeah yeah yeah
yeah charge me an extra hundo kippy's
having fun tonight
what situation do you have you have to
be in will you take maybe
a couple close friends out and you know
you're gonna you're doing better
yeah than that if you took us out today
i'd lie down
i'd lay down my card if we went out to
dinner you would you would choose i know
this is a nice studio yeah patreon's
doing well
those are public numbers so the lights
are all rented
all right t-bone's expensive you know
what i mean
this is this is the best of facebook
marketplace yeah yeah 100
can i make the reservation ruth chris or
not give me shoot me straight those
shirts you got to put in your fish
i'm always a big splitter split it yeah
even on a date
well i'm married now so she pays for
most things
specifically this studio shout out nice
we got a little european mark yeah
there's
we had a foreign investor that uh put up
the upfront seed money
now look at this cup springs all night i
know and you didn't even take the
the wrapper off so that's yeah no you
don't give a [ __ ] yeah
hey you know what her man we'll give him
a little shout out huh what your beak
pulling spring
you get that garbage there's good kids
yeah
so many companies advertising like you
don't need to advertise we know you
exist
yeah yeah yeah like an ad for eminem's
i'm never gonna not
no i'm never gonna not yeah i used to do
a joke about that you could never make
another coke or pepsi commercial again
no one's gonna stop drinking soda we'll
all know
we'll remember forever yeah it's crazy
that's why a lot of companies bowed out
of doing a super bowl this year why
spend the cash
it got us coming anyway you just market
it on facebook there you go
all right now back to dinner hang on
before we get started on here um hungry
man
[Laughter]
so if we went out to dinner you would
throw it down no not for you guys
because you guys
make money really yeah who would it have
to be it would have to be like a
struggling
person yeah open my comments but also
i'd have to like them if i'm going out
to dinner with them i presumably i like
sure sure it's not just like some bum
yeah i got one for you uh if you go out
with your parents
will you be like i got it or is there
like a struggle what's that like
i haven't talked to them in about eight
months right yeah now sometimes i
really saw snipping about that on
instagram if you haven't seen christina
[ __ ] i didn't you gotta go back and
check it out as i start crying
you gotta go back and check it out you
guys are taking a little hiatus
uh my uh yeah well for the foreseeable
future yeah
yeah well because uh talk about i don't
know if there's a garbage move but when
i first started making money i invested
in a house with them
so they didn't have to move to florida
it's never a good idea no yeah yeah yeah
but i own half the house you bought
their house
i did buy on half of it we did an llc so
that i have
so i own property 50 of the llc which
owns the property is it the house you
grew up in
no but it's a really beautiful beach
house in a new jersey town that i
we grew up going to yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and now it's not the house that you
not the house they lived in
correct yeah but they do they were
living in that house i remember so so
no so they lived in pennsylvania we
lived in pennsylvania
yeah um and then when they were gonna
move their budget was florida
and i was like don't but you don't know
anybody there just stay here and
they were gonna move to retire kind of
mm-hmm yeah and so
uh i was like well if i go in on the
house with you we can get this nice
beach house
away from the bay and you can live there
year round and then we can enjoy it
there you go
and now i'm not talking to him
somebody didn't spring for the mac and
manchester of my life really yeah well
now it's just manko's oh yeah it's
because
because of money because of cash no it's
not because of money it's they have some
parties or something like that
illness on on on the side not of mine
sounds a lot like my family yeah
shout out to the ryan so you know
sometimes when you when you don't set a
boundary with a person your whole life
and you just kind of cater to them
and then you're like you know what i'm
going to draw a line in the sand and
they're like
what did you just say you literally
you're like oh my whole entire life
the hell i don't want to be part of and
then one of my um
parents showed up at my apartment after
i specifically said don't do that
and then in the morning i get up when
you when you wake up to a bunch of
missed calls that's never good
it's either really great news very bad
news and it's most likely very
it's a lot of drama are you psycho holy
[ __ ] yeah yeah
my mom's watching us right now and
getting nervous she probably wants us to
move on
because i've been there's been mention
of a short house in in her near future
oh maybe the patreon site what are you
talking about
i cut your checks where are you getting
that where are you getting short out i'm
trying to string this
ain't a luminary okay i'm trying to
string her along a little bit in case i
need a little loan down the line
hang that over he's also he also talks
about like
he's like he was going away and he's
like god forbid the plane crashes you're
you're still gonna have to take care of
my parents
you gotta take care of my mom do you
guys have wills we i we
don't know i own nothing but you got
something
but what if you die if i die tomorrow
i'm getting away with it yeah that it
just got brought up in conversation
craig and i are doing a a finance series
with with luminary with under guys who
[ __ ]
and we've been interviewing all these
finance experts and one of the women was
like you gotta have a will and i was
like really
oh you should have a will yeah you
should but i'm like
i don't talk to my parents i don't have
a boyfriend i don't have kids i'll email
you my social security number
i got a suicide note that's what i got
that's my will yeah pin it all on kippy
i don't know how it got to this point
you only sign your debts away today
he made fun of my shirt yeah no i don't
have a i literally i don't own i don't
own anything i got a 2005
mercury montego that's a car that's
worth about i mean it will want it's
past inspection at this point
they'll have to pay to take it away but
yeah you're gonna have to
of my liquid cash in my account
i just got the spit take off the big man
i might have i'm being honest here i
might hit that camera
this guy is talking about liquid i might
i might have a frozen solid kid
what are you talking about i might have
250
okay well they'll probably go to your
website and i own the government a
couple of bucks too
yeah i'd be blaming that on a pandemic
i i've one thing i've looked into over
the pandemic is if i
die who has to pay my debt does anybody
really
society someone's got to do a nickel on
your behalf
does somebody have your whole bloodline
your whole that's what i looked into
patty foley's on a chain gang i can't
imagine
death is a good way to get out of a bill
oh yeah but i think
nobody's trying to be people there's
like people fake killing themselves it's
passed on
with certain how do you fake kill
yourself you said that uh
we'll talk about it for a while let's
just say my real name's not henry foley
i'll tell you that
ah all right what do you say we get into
some [ __ ] questions here
i think we should we're already cooking
with gas guys i love the fraud
conversation yeah right
i just started talking about my back i'm
like what are we doing here this is
[ __ ] this is yeah jesus christ
uh guys so when you join the um the
patreon we will read your garbage
questions
uh we just get so many every week that
it's the only way to do it so when you
sign up or read your questions that's
where we are at today baby
and speaking of uh you do you have a co
you have a car or no
no i want one though you want one yeah i
want a dodge charger
damn yeah i know i love cars
i'm garb i mean i guess that's a crash
car though like it's cool
but trash but like you know cut off jean
shorts trash yeah yeah that's still true
i like how you double you
i'm hot trash it's fine for sure i would
be intimidated by a girl on a charger
thank you that's good that's what i'm
hoping for my personality is
a girl on the bus what are you talking
about pull up in my o5 montego
she's revving her engine yeah when you
got a spineless personality
you need a car that says don't [ __ ] with
me yeah there you go for sure for sure
what color would it be don't tell me
orange oh what is wrong with you kids
everything is
everybody with the [ __ ] orange these
days i don't want black or
white like ugh what about yellow bumble
bee
no or i'd rather have orange that burnt
orange ain't too shabby though the cops
are looking for that though that's the
new red
oh well what's she doing bank jobs i
don't know oranges is
red with a little yellow she's probably
speeding down the short make sure she
gets it before her parents go
i speed a lot do you oh my god
let me ask you this would you get it
it's so funny i forget that you're like
pure bucks count yo i really forget that
you're like
i went to high school with you you are
yeah you're trying to
remember philly you started you started
up here so right it's stand up yes yeah
yeah
damn uh well this is from pat when
pumping gas do you take the nozzle out
of the car when the dollar amount shows
or do you really hold it in there to get
the last couple of drops out
because me myself i'm a big i let it
click and i do a couple of [ __ ]
[ __ ] i get it all out it's my guess and
i need it now you know what i mean jg
won't worry style
i like an even number oh i gotta do the
evening they've made it a lot
harder to do that they did these days
why because they're [ __ ] dirt balls
and they know what they're doing and
also get trigger happy this is the first
time in my life that i've ever been able
to not say uh you know give me 25 on on
this or give me 15 on that
i actually go i put my card in and i
fill it up you got to fill up money i
got
well you know what i mean i can fill up
money definitely someone's skimming if
someone's taking the skim off the books
here you're paying for our dinner
yeah i don't got fill up that's ayg on
the dark web backslash
um and it uh okay if i do do if i do do
say 25 it starts really slowing down as
it gets closer to 25
oh yeah you're telling me you're gonna
have the technology for that thing to
[ __ ] stop on a dime
right because they want you to [ __ ]
not get the right rest in your poland
springs bottle
no they want you no even they want you
to leave they want you to leave and not
get the full
that was garbage pays anymore though
right who prepays
i rarely prepay yeah usually i don't
but when i do that's the scheme that's a
good point who pre-pays no point prepays
unless you don't have a card yeah unless
you got to do cash
sometimes my card doesn't work at the
pump or anywhere
[Laughter]
truth be told or most establishments
sometimes my card doesn't work at the
pump but it works with the guy i don't
know why
huh it always says secret is not a fun
little ride to go on an emotional roller
coaster
like what yeah i always think the final
foot's gonna drop i know there's 40
bucks in there yeah
i have been terrorized by my car
declining in circumstances that i did
not want that to happen
i i i still regardless of how much money
i do have in my account i've never
confidently swiped my debit or credit
card
ever i have i have five different
excuses ready to go i just deposited a
check i put it yes
i was traveling today i'm a veteran i
got everything demagnetized
yeah which is bad because my wife she
she still has a foreign credit card
because we weren't able to get her
banking [ __ ] set up yet so it's all
foreign so sometimes they just like shut
it down
ah being like oh you've spent too much
money today in a different country
america so then it's on me you know what
i mean so like we'll go shopping should
be like i want this coat and then chill
like
like oh well can you put it on your card
and i'm i mean i'm barely getting by
with a couple of bucks
yeah i was like every time i'm like
please for the life of me let this thing
go through
uh what was he what was the actual
question uh you did do you shake to get
the extra couple of drips out
uh shake it it's not you're not taking
it i just i don't it's that's when you
prepay he's asking
yeah i guess otherwise you would stop on
a dime i'm not that garbage
yeah yeah yeah i guess if you're
pre-paying for gas you're him done i
can't overfill
like if if mine fills up and it says and
it stops on its own it's like 23.31
if i even give it a little bit more it
comes out it spits it up
uh oh yeah my car spits it up it's full
when it's full
way later that's what i thought you were
gonna go do you guys leave the car
running when you pump cast
no really no no i see i do i think
that's old wives tales
why yeah but why leave it all risk it
yeah what do you get out of feel alive i
don't know yeah
roll the dice a little bit i actually
drove by a gas station not that long ago
where the thing went off you know the
suppression
really yeah it was all pink there was
some dude in there too
[ __ ] wiping off his he got he got he
got caught in it
what was he doing he was probably trying
to get gas
and something happened where the [ __ ]
thing went on one thing
the like there's like that system like
the fire extinguisher where it just
shuts down the whole point i've never
experienced
what are you talking about that's
relatively new i feel that i don't think
they don't
have that one in a wawa parking lot when
you have the wawa gas station combo they
have that and everybody smokes
cigarettes in the walla parking like
dangerously close to the pope
and they have a little like please don't
smoke but they're not very forceful
about it like this thing could go up at
any minute you ever know anybody that
pulled away with the nozzle still in it
yes my mom really did my mom do that or
was that my friend's mom somebody
somebody's mom did that yeah jesus yeah
i saw some lady driving down the street
with him one time
they have it set up now so it's not
really that big of a deal yeah it's like
with a new macbook thing you just like
yeah it just connects it just clips out
yeah
um in the same vein this is uh from ryan
in the facebook group
um have you ever used the gas pump
specifically as a parking spot and
didn't get gas
you like pulled wawa
that's the closest i ever come to like
i'm gonna pre-pay yeah that's a real
trashy movie well sometimes those
parking lots are aggressive places
yeah oh for sure it's like fights yeah
yeah you're gonna fight in a gas station
parking lot
i've definitely i've definitely yelled
some things with the windows up for sure
if you want to consider that yeah i'm a
[ __ ] well see that's also
like yeah that's the difference between
girls yeah no one's gonna beat you
up yeah and there's there's well it's
shorter to a fight for sure in
in a guy's especially in a wawa parking
lot in philly yeah but that's what i'm
saying like if
if i keep my headphones i treat it like
a bank job head down don't make eye
contact i've been turning into a spot as
some chick just goes hurt me
and then just takes it and i'm like oh
[ __ ] it's usually in like a [ __ ] 98
cavaliers
or something like that or like a like a
dodge neon with like a spoiler
and you're like ugh which we were just
uh neon is the trashiest like a girl
fight that's adorable my first boyfriend
drive to the dodge neon
really little blue lights on it ah what
color was it white
oh god they only made those in about
three what's he doing now
he's a wedding videographer sounds about
right
yeah still driving that same neon i hope
in my in my mind yes gang i can't tell
you what a hoot kippy and i are having
over there
on the old stereo app we got a fantastic
show where we ask
answer your questions every thursday
night at nine o'clock yeah guys
check it out we're having a good time
baby
i i let loose i have a couple of
cocktails on there it's fun
you guys get to record your garbage
questions you send them in to us we play
them live on the broadcast we answer
them we chop it up it's a good time get
involved
stereo.com kevinryan or slash h foley
we get to with our beaks a little bit
see you there that's right it's live
it's free and it's fun we'll see you
then
kip i gotta be honest with you man
making trips to the post office doesn't
make my day how to do it a couple of
times last week
it's not fun i know you folks out there
don't like making multiple trips to the
post office
that's why we're recommending our new
sponsor and mailing and shipping with
stamps.com stamps.com
allows you to mail and ship anytime
anywhere
right from your computer you can send
letters you can ship packages
do it all baby and you can pay a lot
less because you get discounted rates
from usps ups and more
stamps.com has saved businesses
thousands of hours
and tons of money so what are you
waiting for
with stamps.com you get the services of
the post office and ups
all in one place plus you get big
discounts
on mailing and shipping rates yeah guys
it's easy to use
anybody can do it they're trained a big
man to do it he's he's in charge of
shipping for us
it's easy um you can do it from anywhere
if you got a small business
i know we had a lot of small business
owners to do it um
we use it they hooked us up we've been
sending out the the playing cards using
stamps.com so we're doing it yeah they
send you a scale you get
you get discount uh packaging and
discount they got it all whatever you
need to ship
they got it go to stamps.com it's easy
you can do it from your home your office
your car wherever you got wi-fi
and a computer you can do it it's easy
peasy not to mention stamps.com is a
fraction of the cost of expensive
postage meters baby
talking 40 off post post office right 62
off ups shipping rates what are we doing
here big man who doesn't like to wet
their beak a little do it
um so stop wasting time going to the
post office and go to stamps.com
instead um there's no risk and with our
promo code garbage that's g-a-r-b-a-g-e
you get a special offer that includes
four-week trial four weeks
crazy plus free postage and a digital
scale no long-term commitments or
contracts stick and move easy peasy
go to stamps.com click the microphone at
the top of the home page and use our
promo code
garbage that's stamps.com promo code
garbage
stamps.com never go to the post office
again
now back to the show we would drag race
too
in bucks count like we would like
because i drove a honda and it was stick
shift my parents made me
they're like if you're gonna drive you
have to drive a stick shift because
my mom got ran over by a truck on the
beach once in florida when she was 18
like three days before starting to laugh
that was just not just my mom got ran
over by a truck
she really yeah and she did and she had
to drive herself to the hospital because
her friend couldn't drive stick and so
but and then two days later she met my
dad and my dad was like you look like
you got hit by a truck and he she was
like
well i was on the beach that's how they
met
but yeah so that's why i need to i
needed to learn but i love stick you
have more control of the car
race and go around curves tighter so if
you got the charger you get it and stick
nah
not in the city oh yeah i haven't drove
stick in a while
i never really knew did you yeah and i
had to drive the first yeah same thing i
had we had to learn stick
we were poor my driver's side yes
you failed your driver's test three
times the damn parallel parking
that's the only part that got me i got
psyched myself out
and also in the suburbs i remember being
like i'm not gonna parallel park ever
yeah
yeah and i got the mean guy there was
one guy there's always a guy there
you don't want to get mr roberts yeah
he's like a pensburg or something and
he's like you don't want the guy with
the white beard and the white hair he's
gonna he's gonna like make you feel
terrible the whole time i'm like oh and
i got him all three times jesus
yeah we did we called a three-point turn
back then turn also
yeah yeah did you do uh lessons or did
you just learn with your parents
yeah my parents just my dad taught me in
the parking lot of school yeah and he
got real pissed off that i was [ __ ]
up his clutch i'm like hey you wanted me
to do this so
yeah usually ruin your first clutch yeah
me and my dad got in a fight doing the
same thing
on cathcart road over by montgomery
county community college
oh monica little inside baseball right
yeah yeah that's my blue belt
to the point that i got out of the car
and started walking away and he was in a
passenger seat wow what the [ __ ]
wait he didn't put it in a pocket he's
cruising he's floating away
see you later but we had to go we had to
take the class at monco
for so our insurance would be lower my
mom had all the tricks
yeah yeah smart my dad would just let me
drive his jeep in i was like 15 probably
and he would just like stay in the
parking lot of his office which i mean
it was like a big parking lot
so i was like 15. thought i'd let you
zip around dude i thought i was in a rap
video i had the windows down i was
bumping power nines you remember the
first time you were in a car by yourself
that you
drove to a place do you remember where
you rode to
i don't know but i do remember my mom
saw me driving
like she drove she drove by like my
dad's off and i was like [ __ ] doing
donuts
in the back and she's like what the [ __ ]
are you doing i'm like oh nothing
checking the brakes 25 25 point
inspection i don't remember that i
remember the first time i got on the
highway by myself and i remember being
petrified
yeah scary petrified now i'm doing 90
down the highway i love driving
well you're not getting a charger you're
talking like this come on yeah yeah yeah
no i love driving i
love it i want to get a car just to
drive you go on the road
and do you rent cars or whatever you'd
be like give me the i want like you know
something
fun to do guys yeah the guy at my local
avis knows me so if i go in when he's
there he gives me like one time he gave
me a corvette and i was like yes sir
really you drove a corvette oh my god
yeah well for my birthday
in la when i turned 30 i wanted to rent
a 2019 corvette
and i did and it was [ __ ] man you are
trash
yeah such trash why would you want to
rent a car on your birthday you're going
to get you're going to be when i was in
l.a i needed to rent it anyway yeah
i knew you're going to be boozing yeah i
don't i don't care i don't the booze
yeah whatever i don't i don't need them
i i did some trips where i took an uber
but like i just like driving so much
man that's garbagio to running nice cars
is crazy
yeah why i don't know it's just fun i
know it's just so out of my
wheelhouse i don't know it doesn't make
any sense to me that's too funny
boy in l.a rental cars are cheap in new
york it's yeah it's like 400
a day yeah they get you coming away no
here oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
[ __ ]
that's why i need a guy in new york but
in l.a i can afford it
um pretty trash could have an avis guy
too uh-huh he's a nice guy
you got someone at your local rental
rental car yeah enterprise all right
ava i could say avis but then zipcar i
have a zipcar membership
i got that crazy experience i got
the rent yeah the rentals are but it's
like nice to not deal with anybody the
last rental i got
because i did a gig in long island and i
was like i'm gonna drive to it i had
credits on my zip code
it the the car had just been crashed
into it
and i was like really and then you open
this sucker you open the door and you're
like this is
did someone diarrhea everywhere like it
was
stained crumbs and i'm like ugh i missed
my avis guy
yeah i i did zipcar once or it was i
forgot what it was i had that and like
enterprise did it too i had a couple of
them like and i was always like trying
to jock you who it was like my first
uber who had the cheaper deal yeah
i'll do this and i went was that like uh
like a parking lot you know what i mean
like just like a parking garage and i
went in
and i guess not a lot of people use it
and it was there and the attendants had
the keys to it they're like well this is
not really one person's car this is just
like this
car so the attendants used to just sit
in it and smoke
dude i literally pulled up i'm like yeah
i'm here to check out the zip car or the
camry or whatever and there was a guy
smoking a blonde and i was like uh he
was like yeah here you go man just put
the four windows i'm like
all right but i'm like can you call i
got that reminded me i'm like can you
call i want to call zipcar and be like
why did you give me a car that was
crashed into like can i get my money
should at least get some more credit
get credits yeah um
damn all right let's see this this
episode is not brought to you by zip
code
uh this is from alex sherman when you
were a kid this is a
100 dirt ball move when you were a kid
did your parents ever take your bedroom
door away holy [ __ ] that was all i had
was my bed bedroom door yeah
no no no no no i did not yeah i think
she did foley what'd you do
i don't know you're not gonna close that
door in my house no one's jerking off
into my room is that caught touching
yourself
jesus sees everything henry we were
never allowed to have our doors closed
by yourself no we weren't allowed to
have the doors closed
why sounds like some commie [ __ ]
this is america basically they knew what
we were doing in there
listen fedor was close to my house
somebody was jerking off yeah
well it didn't matter who the plumber
your mom anybody
didn't matter who it was fully jerked
off like he was in a p.o.w
i was getting whipped only have a minute
before you jerk off behind your door
that's open oh
that's pretty good the freddy krueger
you gotta be okay yeah
he's gotta be okay doing it standing up
did you have to have the bathroom door
open bathroom
[Laughter]
no you were allowed to have the bathroom
doorbell i don't think we were allowed
to lock it
it doesn't lock yourself i thought we
weren't allowed but we didn't
it was clearly frowned upon yeah it was
clear why is the door
locked what are you doing in there it'd
be like that
give me some [ __ ] privacy just watch
married with children what do you think
i'm doing in here
i'm working that would get you going
where'd you check off in your car
where'd you jerk off
um in my car what am i at 12 years old
with a car
oh i'm thinking at the office uh
in my bed oh in my bed at night with the
with the door open and the windows down
yeah
set the alarm for 3 am to wake up make
sure the rest of the house is sleeping
knocked the dog out uh no but i remember
she took the door they took the
they took my door off the hinges and set
it there
wow time i can't remember why what i did
i'm sure i deserved it
i don't know i i think so probably you
probably did yeah i can
from what i know i know if we live
together i would have taken your door
off
i was a real bad kid i was a bad kid
he's a bad adult what are we talking
about what'd you do
as a kid that was bad that caused a lot
of trouble um
get more specific never cleaned my room
ran off at the mouth
uh gotten some fights in high school and
stuff like that
i mean but that's kid stuff yeah it's
like the sand lot you know what i mean
yeah
killed my neighbor i drowned the dog
oh damn yeah i don't i never had that no
um all right this is are you allowed to
have your doors locked yeah i mean it
was the the parents were divorced it was
just my name
um she was working it was like they got
other fish to fry yeah it was like his
and my brother was bad it was like as
long as
i knew i'm like well there's the line if
i just hang out
if i hang out in the back i mean if i'm
not the biggest problem that day i'm
cool
yeah sure i just [ __ ] he was the one
he was the one storming the beach i was
just hanging out in the back you were
allowed to have your door locked
uh i was yeah i could have it locked no
one yeah no one ever
you have a brother yeah an older brother
an older brother yeah yeah so i feel
like girls got away with their doors
being closed more
yeah i guess i mean it's a privacy thing
my parents are younger girls yeah but
they are they also
yeah but young boys we're humans you
know we don't need privacy more or less
than you
but uh my parents were fighting so much
that they didn't have time to worry
about it
ah nice so yeah i see the fighting
continued too
just with you now yeah um well this is
in the same vein this is from corey did
the front door of your house open up
directly into your living room
we had a foyer but my parents did smoke
where else would it open
my parents did smoke cigarettes in their
garage closed
captioning not available yeah
um were you like a smoking section kid
like we were the when we went somewhere
we were in the smoking section no we
didn't do that they kept the smoking to
uh the garage would they go out when
you're eating a meal would they would
your mom or dad get up during the meal
and go out and have a smoke i don't
remember
that's always trash maybe maybe yeah
they probably did i know we didn't sit
in the smoking section my dad never did
it but my dad would get up and or my mom
would get up and like you know after the
appetizers between the entrees
that's one of the beautiful things about
a cigarette is like the break from
whatever yeah
it's the escape that's the thing i like
about it oh of course i want to quit one
day for sure but i'm like i still want
that escape i need a reason to go stand
outside for three minutes yeah smoke at
a wedding is really nice
uh especially because people are smoking
that don't normally say hey who's got
him you feel like yeah i feel like a
drug dealer like
over here here's some real garbage have
you ever been to this
the one smoking section at disneyland oh
it is
the most difficult yeah yeah yeah yeah
it is so sad it's like people with no
arms yeah tobacco town
yeah and there's only one smoking
section so you're all like
herded into this little fence of shame
everyone's just
nasty and you're like you're like an
exhibit for everybody else to look at
ricky the mouse yeah and all the parents
are like that's what you could end up
like honey and you're like
all right [ __ ] you guys there's a
smoking section of disneyland
there's one in each part like each park
or whatever it's just like a little
corral where you want
smoke but in six lectures there's not
right money smoking well six flags is a
little
lower you know lower caliber human than
than disney disney's about a [ __ ] a
jihad to get in there
six flags is a can of coke even
disneyland
what's disneyland california i've never
been is that the one you're talking
about yeah there's one smoking section
yeah wait did you go there
as a kid no disneyland is an adult okay
i was going to say
did you go to disney world as a kid yes
my grandparents lived in florida yep
pretty good mm-hmm cried on the e.t ride
you ever hit the smoking section of an
airport
yeah i've walked by them and because
some said some places don't have them
but i'm like
i've never seen this really it's like
it's like a shed
in the tournament yeah it's it's glass
doors and all you
they're clear but you can't see anything
because there's just so much you're in a
hot box and you're
in a sauna some japanese businessmen on
their last leg
yeah i was just saying i went away i
went to this nice resort uh last weekend
for my anniversary
and they had a they had a sig hut like
pokemon relax
very nice though it's it's very nice he
shits on it um was it in the poconos
it wasn't not in the pokemon
it's called the it's called woodlock
lodge it's very nice very expensive and
we could have went to [ __ ] europe for
for the amount of money we [ __ ] spent
but they had a they had a sig hut
yeah it's a gazebo with a heater and i
was nobody else was in it for the
like 48 hours i was there except me and
i was loving it
i was treating it like my vip section in
there i had my feet up i was in my robe
just going to town have you ever bought
a carton i've never bought a carton i
can't move myself to do it because it's
too garbage
it is even though it's physically
responsible uh well not anymore it is
than it used to be
oh um you used to get like a price break
on them now it's just the same
price but when i would go really yeah i
think that changed a couple of years ago
um when i was when i first moved up here
and we were really [ __ ] poor like you
know doing open mics and [ __ ] yeah
and i would go down to philly i would
get a carton in philly because it was
like i don't know 60 bucks or 70 bucks
or something whereas a pack here was
like 14 bucks yeah no my when i was a
kid i would drive we would drive down
from
virginia to north carolina to get a
cartons of cigarettes because my
just four cartons yeah oh god
it was like a 12-minute draw we lived in
chesapeake virginia so it was close okay
but it was like you know like a 20 30
minute drive but just to get cartons
anytime you cross state lines for
tobacco fireworks
or alcohol yeah it's bad news philly the
big thing was right at delaware and get
the booze oh
or people go to delaware to get like tvs
and stuff something on a sales tax
yeah um this i don't know who this was
but have you ever been
oh here it is this is from uh kristen
have you ever been drunk
at an amusement park no
i don't like day drinking daydream
sleepy get her
out of here i'm just gonna go to sleep
right away yeah i'm gonna go to bed
right away so you gotta
it's like it's a game you gotta push
through it you can't slow down
i'm not i don't have that hutzpah in me
i don't have the push have you been
drunk at an amusement park
oh yeah i mean you do the countries at
disney world you get a drink in each
country we're trash
we go as a whole family because you go
to all like that's in epcot i guess so
you do all the
magic kingdom and whatever and then you
go
to i think it's epcot has eat the
countries right there's like china and
germany
and in each place you get a different
drink they have like a cocktail of
fun i would do that yeah i made it to
like [ __ ] japan before i caused a
[ __ ] scene dude
i was a godzilla in that [ __ ] i
was [ __ ] yelling and [ __ ]
[ __ ] does that mean i can't have another
one you get cut off at ep
by the time you get to like yeah by the
time you get to asia you're smoking
wherever it doesn't matter
kicked out of yugoslavia i imagine when
i smoke it's like a french girl but it's
not how it comes off
no that's the other thing fresh people
smoke way hotter oh your europeans do it
it's very like i tried but i'm like
i'm real bad with it the fat guy smoking
is bad yeah and it's a shirt on top
parking garage it sticks on me more the
smoke i don't know
he comes in here and he's like how you
doing and it's it's tough wow
it's it's like a bus driver yeah maybe
when you if you sweat
while you smoke maybe and it just gets
absorbed well there's a bigger surface
air there's more cloth to get stuck on
gets in my clothes comforter smoking
like a fire blanket with a cigarette but
i feel like when a girl smokes sometimes
like that smell is kind of sexy because
there's like oh really
that mix of cigarette and perfume you
remember that when you were a kid oh
yeah
that's my mom ew
yeah you just described patty oh henry
take your door off the hinges
i'm coming over you're jerking off again
pull your little peen around i want to
take a picture
shout out to patty who's watching this
right now weird
no you don't remember that that was that
was the most
genuine weird ever i loved it yeah we
all have
our own relationship with our own mother
that's unique you don't remember like
the babysitter when you were a kid like
the hot babysitter that like had us
that smelled like perfume and a
cigarette no
most of my i'm the weirdo no i'm no i i
i understand what you're saying but i
didn't sexualize i've seen a couple
years loser not too shabby
yeah you're closer in age to them than
me um
all right let's see this is from nick uh
has your family ever taken a cast off at
home to save a trip to the dock
which i my brother has taken his own off
for sure
and i've helped a friend take theirs off
i never had a cast
really but i did um dislocate my elbow
while my parents were having an amway
meeting in their living room
and let me tell you something oh my god
it hurt my brother wait what's
amway amway that's the pyramid scheme
it's like avon
yeah it's like avon but like trash avon
if you can imagine and why you they sell
like stakes and stuff that's so funny
because like on the surface you look so
like i'm not man you are pure garbage
yeah
oh man doing an egg mom can we go to the
hospital i dislocated my elbow no let me
finish this [ __ ] pyramid scheme
let me tell you how many steaks i sold
in little christina be quiet with
grifton over here we need this money
look at elbow
you'll go late bring her in that's the
final pitch
my mom pushed uh avon for a little bit
yeah my grandma did avon a little skin's
so soft
and my parents we had a lot of avon like
glassware growing up we also had a lot
of trump
glasses like from the casinos they all
they went to the casinos a lot
what did they play did they have like a
game they played i don't know i thought
slots
yeah you seem like slots people yeah
yeah i'm not gonna lie
yeah but you guys i'm getting
[Laughter]
old nickel slot hutchinson everybody
uh i was such a prude i liked to think i
was islamic what did your parents do
growing up
job-wise dad was in the navy drafted
into the navy
yeah yeah he got drafted a week before
he got his college acceptance letter
so he was like all right i guess i'm
doing this and then he stuck with it
and then he had all these jobs
afterwards that were like very confusing
for me he was a chief in the navy
and then i remember he worked at pizza
hut after he retired
he got held up by gunpoint twice and
he's like all right
what pizza hut in virginia beach damn
and then he swept it on there he drove
one of those parking lots
sweepers yeah and i'm like wait you were
just in the navy
huh yeah that's a nice that's uh i think
he just wanted something to do that's a
that's an odd move
damn yeah he's like i just want to see
see what this is like
but he's a car guy too so i thought he
was gonna you know do car stuff but no
he was a car guy that's where you get to
charge your phone oh yeah he has a 76
trans am that i almost bought but now
we're not that's the that's nice but
that's the trash
[Applause]
i wish but it was white with the blue
stripes and the blue bird
yeah oh i know there you go that's a
good car for you and my brother's first
car was a 68 camaro
because she's trash yeah that's what i
mean yeah yeah yeah we had we had though
we had a we lived in a nice neighborhood
because we had our house built in
virginia was cheap but it was like you
know nice
nice or after uh pennsylvania this is
before before
i was born in pa moved to virginia for
10 years back came back yeah uh
it's a lawrence clear-up parent uh we
went
junkin so my parents had an antique
store in a flea market right you would
go through people's trash
to get to collect stuff and we had a van
that was so
disgusting looking that our neighbors
would like
brightest passive aggressive letters to
say like you need to move that
what kind of van was it it was i don't
know what the brand was but it was just
like
all every kind of brown you can imagine
striped
like plaid it was a plaid van it was bad
it smelled like cat pissed what did your
dad want for the for the trans am was it
was he giving you a good deal or no i
don't remember
37 thousand dollars was just recently
yeah
oh i was going to buy it a year ago and
then we kind and then covet happen we're
like i don't know but i wouldn't drive
it in the city i'm like i've got to keep
it a garage
i'm not going to drive that in the city
you have to keep the charger in a garage
too if you got an absolutely but i would
i would be able to drive that you know i
could drive people around in that that
could sit you know it's two
two door the one that i'm thinking of
but it has good back seats yeah
it's a big car yeah yeah bulky um damn
all right this is from mike have you
ever had black lights or black light
accessories
yeah i have one now i got one i went to
spencer's gifts with karen we went to
the american dream mall and those
youtubers your place is a little tripped
out too
i know you have wait oh hold on put a
pin in there you have the coolest
apartment by the way thank you for that
[ __ ]
little hut or whatever you call that
it's a nut there it's like a nook
it's like a little weird room yeah it's
like an elevated weird clubhouse
it's really cute that you can't stand up
in it's nice um
yeah so i bought one of those like
globes where you turn it on and there's
all these like pink
stuff and when you touch it it like the
static one yeah
it's awesome [ __ ] it's so cool dude that
is
it's only 25 growing up did you have the
stars on the ceiling
yes i did the planets the planets man
we had a blacklight in college but that
was just for acid purposes
it had a function yeah you got a couple
scientists why else
i guess it's just a trippy look the
black light other than like did someone
jizz on my bed
yeah now unless you're doing drugs i
don't know why you would have a black
light
wait they're for drugs yeah i mean to
what drug
cocaine no to be like look at that it's
cool i guess oh like do drugs and then
turn the black light out
exactly okay any time you do drugs
as of trip out as a freshman in college
you roll up to a party and they got a
black light it was always a roll the
dice to see what was going to be on your
you're like ah it's you [ __ ]
you're like i spilled a meatball on
there earlier whatever you know
[ __ ] every stain shows up you look
like a real jerk off
oh yeah i hated that yeah i guess a
black light is a douchey move at a party
yeah
yeah let's see who doesn't clean
themselves exactly
that's some uh passive aggressive
bullying
talk about microaggressions yeah that'd
be pretty fun hit people with the
blacklight when they walk into your
place just check yet
you want to be allowed in anywhere you
guys should sneak in i mean i guess you
could only do it once the bit wouldn't
work unless but like
all of a sudden you're talking to
somebody who you think has just all over
them
and drop the lights drop the lights and
just switch into party mode
that'd be fun oh i like it prank time i
could do that in here
i love that's the idea yeah replace yeah
um damn all right this is from nick do
you uh
do you pick things out while shopping
and decide you don't want them and just
drop them wherever yes
oh man i was going to start an instagram
account called [ __ ] these groceries and
it was just like misspelled it's pretty
funny actually
a pack of ham and like a cereal
groceries
groceries i can't do clothes i i i go
through like it's my closet
no i have i got a bigger bone to pick
with you groceries who cares
it's whatever it's chaos already
someone's got to fold those clothes
though
so you're going to you're going to ruin
that product what i'm saying
if there's yeah if you're you've got a
[ __ ] 16 pound ham yeah don't put it
with the [ __ ]
canned goods but i mean if you if you
have a thing a
can of corn you can put it with the
beans or whatever i don't know
no yeah all right but it's disorienting
to see
if you take it off the shelves they
can't sell it anymore yeah you're
talking about perishable items
and then yes they do they put that [ __ ]
right back oh they do yeah i've worked
it i feel like i've worked at groceries
clothing stores are set up weird
like you don't have to make it that hard
for everyone to like who works there
you know one little flick of the rack
and it's all [ __ ] it's awful i
hate it i just have to fold [ __ ] i full
i folded three thousand pairs
what are you gonna do otherwise what do
you mean when he's hanging out you're
working
you should go around keep folding i
[ __ ] hate you
you're in the dressing room do you have
this in a 7xl
[Laughter]
shocker they don't fit meanwhile someone
asks the [ __ ]
food runner for a water fully will stab
you in your throat yeah meanwhile like
if you don't
if you don't have perfect etiquette in a
[ __ ] restaurant you get mad when
people want to split the bill or living
in a society here yeah as you're
throwing t-shirts behind you like a jerk
it's a society till you step into
hollister then it's [ __ ] vietnam
and first of all i only shop at low end
places i do it at like kmart and walmart
they're expecting animalistic behavior
they'd be suspect if i did put it back
this guy's a narc
this guy just folded his own t-shirt
this has a narc that's how you get
stabbed you turn around
can you ever try to fold it and you're
like yeah this is why when you're like
yeah you try
i try like a pinterest fail where you
try to make a cake that looks like
mickey mouse and it just looks like an
[ __ ] i'm always impressed that people
do know how to do that well
that can fold closely i always fold it i
always put it back
at least make an attempt where it goes
yeah yeah it's nice and i'll even
like fit it's just because i've been
i've been so mad at someone who's like
picked up a t-shirt and then dropped it
well that's wrong
like a freshly stacked thing yeah i
[ __ ] hate it it's a big pet peeve of
mine
it's true what do you want from field
attention yeah um
this is from izana have you ever had to
ask a friend for your your
or has a friend ever asked you for urine
or have you ever asked anything you know
not to go to me
no [ __ ] have you ever had to go to
anybody for it i'm i've never had a test
oh i don't know
i if a job requires me to give them a
year example that's not a company
i don't like your mission statement yeah
[ __ ] nurse i believe this is
intrusive on personal rights
yeah i've had people ask have asked me
for for sure because i never really i
never smoked weed in high school
so i was uh i always had i always had
the goods if you needed it
we always just did the thing you get a g
and c the gallon thing
but it's like what is marijuana gonna do
to your job
you know i mean if you suck at your job
you suck at your job it's not because of
the weed
get you kicked off the football team oh
yeah
i guess it's no good is that how you get
kicked off the football team no
were you on the football team i was on
the football team but there was always
threats to get into the football team
and yeah we were slowly if you're
smoking that cheap you're gonna hit the
bricks
we were smoking doobies so we'd get that
gallon tea anytime there was ever a
threat of it
yeah i was a few kids we were all high
and fingering each other and no one
cared damn i should have been in the
theater
could have been high fingering myself
yeah yeah yourself
damn hey where's everybody else
[Laughter]
that's where she approached me okay why
is there a black light on me what's
going on
um all right this is from matthew is it
classy or garbage to put your chocolate
candy in the freezer before eating it
i mean i do it gentlemen's moves yeah i
think it's the right move
a gentleman's it's a whole different
piece of candy that's a sure it's a
different
elevating the experience especially for
storage if you're not going to get to it
right away
yeah and just adding temperature to
texture 100
if you could why wouldn't you what's
your go-to candy bar chocolate can
chocolate bar what are you doing
you going like high-end or you're going
like snickers what are you doing no i do
reese's
i love freezing or reese's oh man talk
about america right there
that's right frieza reese's all day
daddy oh [ __ ] an apple pie
right there yeah fourth of july she was
a whole host
though red white and blue i'll tell you
that a reese's peanut butter cup good
night
they're coming out with a show based on
the uh diversity uh history channels the
men who made america
no they're coming out with one the
candies that made america
the whole story of like hershey's and
all these people
yeah are you narrating it have you gone
to hershey the hershey ride and her
spencer's been hershey
me too many times yeah that was like
that was
fancy not fancy for us though but like
it was a step up from six points yeah
the
the default was six flags and it was
like you we did six flags every now and
then but then hershey was only like
we've done twice
it's like yeah six flags your life is in
the hands of a 15 year old but then
hershey your life is in the hands of
like a 20-something amish woman yeah
and you can have a nice dinner right yes
yeah and see a show
ma'am six flags i haven't been to a six
flags in a long time but i mean the
clientele there is tough
oh it's bad crazy i remember i was a cam
counselor one time and we went to six
flags like as
like we took all the kids to six flags
show you what can happen to you
[Laughter]
you don't stay in school and there was
multiple people wearing jeans
in the wave pool and i was like what are
we doing why do you hate yourself what
are we doing
i'm like i'd rather you naked or
interrupt yourself yeah i remember the
safari at great adventure was pretty i
never got to go on that it wasn't bad
was that with the animals well yes we
never did it
we never liked that well you go through
the smoking section
in a minivan i was not a safari i wasn't
sure
that was never i mean first of all i
don't think giraffes are indigenous to
new jersey by the way
okay you would think not but that was
like uh that was the thing
my dad would be like we don't do that
that's not for us that's for europeans
and idiots or something i don't know
that wasn't something we did everything
was your opinion i don't know what he
had against them
crafts are not in europe either but i
never said the man was smart okay
you would hit a petting zoo though right
oh i love you at the state fair at the
at the pennsylvania state fair at the
racetrack i don't know if you ever did
that at the right time
i did that i went to local fairs petting
zoos are the [ __ ]
oh my god i famously i think we've
talked about this a couple times a
famous people
gave bubble gum to a pot belly pig me
and my boy pat did it die
no he sat there and chewed the bubble
gum for five hours
and it was the funniest thing i've ever
seen
oh my that never ends we just laughed
forever it was great were you high
no i don't think so just a couple of
kids out on the town
it's like foley with a knicker head
yeah i think we ran out of quarters
start smoking um damn all right couple
more here
uh this is from tank have you ever taken
outside food into a different restaurant
[Laughter]
which like that's unforgivable to me no
no because i no no i've
well the last place i waited tables that
was bear burger
and then uh in nyu worst little [ __ ]
pieces of [ __ ] ouch ever
excuse me sir ingredient list for your
buns
there was a couple of guys that i almost
fought and i saw one of them he was he's
a professor there
this was months later after i quit i was
i was
i was leaving the city i was in the car
i was on 58th street and second avenue
about to cross over to the bridge
and out of nowhere him and this guy just
walk across the street i swear to god
i thought about running this guy over
wow such a
[ __ ] prick it was this one professor
that had like uh
what do they call when people study
together group study
something like that yeah they would all
they would i like how you couldn't put
use
what's it called when a group studies
together room studies something like
that i didn't go to a fancy school like
nyu all right
i was waiting tables to [ __ ] bear
burger in the guardian place
[ __ ] nightmare but they would all
come in 42 at the time they would all
come in and they would expect to be
treated like [ __ ] gold none of them
were paying the professor paid
which i assume the college paid probably
my tax dollars at work they're [ __ ]
feeding these kids
and they were such [ __ ] dicks would
they say stuff to you they would they
talk to you
they would they would they would just be
so like can i get it they were just such
a [ __ ] can you not eat my burger
hey i said we do things around here one
for me too for you i want to share
better you get poisoned or something
like that how did you quit did you have
a big quit like
i'm sick of this place no the the last
day that i worked there
it was uh it was like right around
memorial day of last summer
and they just started pulling staff away
left and right like it just got worse
and worse and worse
and it was like me and one guy on the
floor all right and they had the [ __ ]
outside open and these people came in
and though i almost got into a fight
with the one kid cause he's like he's a
little french kid he's like he's like
why isn't that a table ready i'm like
you got to give me a minute
i mean literally i'm not standing there
[ __ ] watching sportscenter right i'm
running around [ __ ] sweat
and he's still [ __ ] breaking my balls
and i finally stopped i was like listen
man
your table's not ready [ __ ] relax or
something like that and then his buddy
and then every the sound stopped the
music stopped yeah
what did you just say to our customer
exactly then his buddy went over and
pitched at me to my uh general manager
but then the next day i just called and
said hey i'm not coming anymore
take that's it yeah take that take that
burger boy you still need that last
check though big man
still gonna need that corporate discount
but they would bring
you working he's a good weight as much
as i give him and break his balls he's a
really good waiter you would be a great
raider but they're
very personable but like just like a a a
high like a stick up their ass clientele
and you
not i worked in fine dining i could
handle that it was just
they were just little [ __ ] pricks
they were [ __ ] and they would bring in
their own food all the time
like dude you can't eat that in here but
everybody else is eating you know what
is
it
what they bought here
european [ __ ]
i've gone on i was a i was uh
a valet at a car dealership with me and
two of my buddies
and uh a valet i validated a car
dealership with me and two of my buddies
and we tried to
we went on strike demanding a two dollar
raise an hour or something
wow you went on strike you like and they
were like yeah get out of here and i was
like all right see ya
you know that was they were like i was
like yeah they're like no we don't
we're not doing that i was like all
right well later man who i should have
some kind of
flexibility i was in college it was a
summer job for me my two
idiot buddies working there as their
like career
yeah and i was like dude [ __ ] it it's
like it's memorial day weekend let's get
the [ __ ] out of here and go down the
shore you know what i mean yeah
rosa parks and then they quit and like
take a hike buddy my buddy had to
he was afraid to tell his mom that he
quit because he was still living at home
so he had to dress up
in the morning and leave until she left
the house and then he would come back
and hang out during the day
wow i wish i wish i wish i quit so many
times
i i worked so many times what did you do
before you before you uh you know
got uh rich and famous and successful
what was your last day job
in new york last day job in new york was
at a wework
okay yeah yeah i scan [ __ ] in the
accounting department
and they actually i got it through
temping i tempt a lot and they're like
what do
you know we want you to come on and stay
on and i was like great and then they're
like what do you want your title to be
i'm like going to be scanner girl
and they're like she was a scanner girl
yeah i'm like i'm a scanner girl
but i worked at a restaurant when i was
in college i was just so
meek and just intimidated by everything
and the
this fancy restaurant in union or in um
lincoln square
lincoln center right across the street
from lincoln center is this italian
place
it was very they sang when it was your
birthday they had like an opera group
come out and sing like it was rich
i know the joint you're talking about
larry king went there all that like fee
someone with an f and they told i was a
hostess and they told me that i needed
to wear more makeup and i was just like
oh my god no no they go i'm sorry they
go
you need to wear makeup when you come in
here and i was like i i
am wearing makeup but instead of going
[ __ ] this [ __ ] i was like maybe i'll
just put on more makeup tomorrow
did you jor you have to look at me yeah
man
[ __ ] i didn't know how to use my
words i didn't know how to use my words
to stand up for myself so it really just
a lot of
just a lot of i can't stand this for one
more second you really wait until the
your
top's about to burst that's always the
way i am and then it's you look back on
that [ __ ] and you were like you
just could have removed yourself from
the situation with respect and dignity
attached yeah cause like that's
that was that's the thing with those
jobs is like you do you're like [ __ ]
this is like so ridiculous
yeah and you're so angry walking around
you don't get that like working in
restaurants it's a [ __ ] nightmare
yeah and then you become that guy that
psycho guy
that's yelling at everybody that they
didn't do their side work because
they're so frustrated oh that yeah yeah
you let it out well i worked at a
[ __ ]
i worked at a a law firm that
represented
banks in during the mortgage crisis so
we were like they were like taking
people's houses
and it was i was like the devil but like
i worked i worked in the accounting side
of it so i'm like well i'm not rea and i
need the money
i'm not really i'm not really the devil
and it was always it was like short term
i just i needed i had no money it was
either that or be homeless so yeah yeah
yeah yeah
so i was working there like your clients
and yeah there we go and
that's a good one fully i got in a fight
with my boss who like she hated him she
just [ __ ] hated me
and i was like i was like you know
whatever like and i was going to lunch
when this fight started so i was like i
just walked out
yeah i'm like yeah whatever you know
whatever like it wasn't like [ __ ] you i
quit or anything i was just like
whatever and i went got two slices of
[ __ ] pepperoni like a [ __ ]
gentleman
like one does and i came back to a
company-wide email of 800 people saying
kevin ryan has quit the firm
she thought i'm out of here
i came back and everybody looked at me
and they were like what are you doing
were you like
that's not what i meant yeah i'm like no
i was just going on like i clocked we're
finally talking here
well i can't like pretend uh pretentious
when you're whenever you work as
pretentious people it's right
the last one of the last college jobs i
have was at the apple store and we would
deal with a lot of
when people's phones don't work they get
really upset and apple
did a i see why they do this now they
train you more in customer service and
product knowledge
yeah so that you can problem solve
situations most people suck
yeah oh 100 and when their phone's not
working they're they're you know brings
out the worst in humanity
so i would do the genius bar after hours
in the soho store and so you could only
do an appointment and we would have all
these people come
rich people like but i need to get in
you're like you can't i can't like you
can't yeah
and so it like i got to let my anger out
on them because i was like who do you
think you are yeah and then there's this
one lady the security guard is like hey
this woman she doesn't have an
appointment and i was like
and i went i was like you need an
appointment and then i went back
upstairs and the guy was like hey
that's steve job's his daughter and i
was like oh [ __ ] oh she needs
a job it was lisa jobs and i was like yo
girl
why you got such an old macbook she had
like the oldest macbook and i was like
oh yeah i would have still made her
steve job would respect you for that
yeah yeah nobody plays ball here stevie
all right everybody waits in line all
right
let's do one or two more and hit the
bricks how does that sound
i love it uh this is from brian it's
also true that like so many of
our [ __ ] listeners are just like
knuckleheads that all have the same name
as my fat like i have
multiple family members with these like
all the same names shout out to brian
sullivan uh
have you ever made a new email address
for the sole purpose to use it to get
another free round of trials or apps or
streaming or anything
no wait said it again have you ever used
a second or made a new email address
to get another round of free trials
made a new email address to get an
instagram account to stalk somebody
that's it
what light light light and then i was
like this is stupid that's the only time
i've ever
x i presume yeah well no i think it was
a current
person who was live this was a while ago
and you were trying to catch him in a
lie
yeah and then it didn't work did you no
yeah
case came up dry huh like i also what
did you expect to say like do you think
he was going to be posting other
pictures or like
i don't know oh i thought i was
convinced i don't know what happened
what that situation was i just remember
like i felt so sneaky
and i was like this is the lead i'm
lying about my identity
garbage and nuts yeah
my kind of guy she's got it she's got it
all folks i feel too guilty to do
anything bad
that's why when i was making this fake
account i'm like oh god i hope this is
okay
yeah i do it all the time i've one i was
i think it was like to use like for like
subtitles to put on videos
yeah you can use it and it's free your
first time
but they don't you don't have to confirm
the email you know like it doesn't like
send you an email to confirm it you just
have to enter
an email so i'm just doing like kevin
ryan won
i have a couple out there for shifty
shifty things
porn yeah you're buying porn
kevin doesn't know what he's talking
about he's a kid
cut the tape toby your mom's going to
come in and take out the hinges of this
door
[Laughter]
that's the button on the show what a tie
i got callbacks
yeah what a hoot christina hutchinson
thank you for sitting with us what do
you want the folks out there to know
that coming up yeah i have my solo
podcast voices in our heads available
everywhere
uh my social media at christina hutch
but it's k-r-y-s-t-y-n-a and i didn't
pick it
people think i picked the spelling of my
name i'm like what no
um and then i'm i'm on tour a bunch i'm
gonna be in portland philadelphia uh
baltimore
uh a lot of places but if you go to my
name christinehutchinson.com it's all
there
buddy we love you thank you for coming
with us
great family episode great company
episode kippy what do you got to tell
them let them know
uh first of all at cameron comedy on all
social media come on and then obviously
please make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes we're in the top 200
uh subscribing and rating and reviewing
helps those numbers out you can do
that even if you watch it you can
[ __ ] you know download itunes and
subscribe
also uh you can subscribe on youtube
full
hd video available there and then
patreon.com
check it out yes sir thank you guys at
each fully on ice on twitter fully grams
on instagram
we love you and we'll see you next week
peace hold on a quick second there
cowboys and cowgirls want to take one
more
quick minute and talk to you about the
old stereo app
kippy and i are having a fun time there
thursday nights at nine o'clock
yeah i don't know why you turned into a
prospector doll this time but we're
having a good old time down there this
is he
uh guys go to the stereo uh the stereo
app is great you can download it use our
link it'll be in the description of this
episode at stereo.com
kevinryan or stereo.com hfoley we get to
wet our beaks a little bit
it's a free app for you guys and we
answer your garbage questions live
on air uh and every time we do we got a
couple hundred people in there it's a
party baby
it's a good time we have a lot of fun i
have a couple of cocktails
i let my hair down you know what i mean
i'm sitting there in my undies it's a
good time
a lot of great shows on there not just
ours it's fantastic app it's free it's
fun
get in on there android iphone doesn't
matter
sign up today